que las hipótesis extraterrestres siempre deben ser el último recurso.
Quiero contar una historia al respecto.
Esta incluye datos de una misión de la NASA,
gente común y una de las estrellas más extraordinarios en nuestra galaxia.
Se inició en 2009 con el lanzamiento de la misión Kepler de la NASA.
El principal objetivo científico de Kepler
era encontrar planetas fuera de nuestro sistema solar.
Se hizo esto mirando un solo campo en el cielo,
este, con todas las pequeñas cajas.
Y en este un campo,
se supervisó el brillo de más de 150 000 estrellas
de forma continua durante cuatro años,
teniendo un punto de datos cada 30 minutos.
Buscaba aquello que los astrónomos llaman un tránsito.
Esto es cuando la órbita del planeta está alineada en nuestra línea de visión,
para que el planeta pase por delante de una estrella.
Y cuando esto sucede, bloquea un poco de luz de las estrellas,
que se puede ver como un baño en esta curva.
Y por eso el equipo de la NASA ha desarrollado equipos muy sofisticados
para buscar tránsitos de todos los datos de Kepler.
Al mismo tiempo de la primera publicación de los datos,
los astrónomos de la Universidad de Yale se preguntaban algo interesante:
¿Qué pasa si las computadoras perdieron algo?
Por eso se inició el proyecto de ciencia ciudadana llamada cazadores de planetas
para incorporar a gente observando los mismos datos.
El cerebro humano tiene una capacidad asombrosa para reconocer patrones,
a veces incluso mejor que una computadora.
Sin embargo, había mucho escepticismo al respecto.
Mi colega, Debra Fischer, fundadora del proyecto Planet Hunters,
dijo que la gente entonces decía:
"Están locos. No es posible que una computadora pierda una señal.
Y así continuó el clásico juego de azar humano contra la máquina.
Y si encontramos un planeta, estaríamos encantados.
Cuando me uní al equipo hace cuatro años,
ya habíamos encontrado una pareja.
Y hoy, con la ayuda de más de 300 000 entusiastas de la ciencia,
hemos encontrado docenas,
y también hemos encontrado una de las estrellas más misteriosas
en nuestra galaxia.
Así que para entender esto,
les enseñaré cómo es un tránsito normal en los datos de Kepler.
En este gráfico en el lado izquierdo representa la cantidad de luz,
y en el fondo es el tiempo.
La línea blanca es la luz solo de la estrella,
lo que los astrónomos llaman una curva de luz.
Al transitar un planeta por una estrella, bloquea un poco de esta luz,
y la profundidad de este tránsito refleja el tamaño del objeto en sí.
Y así, por ejemplo, tomemos Júpiter.
Los planetas no llegan a ser mucho más grandes que Júpiter.
Júpiter hará una caída del 1 % en el brillo de una estrella.
La Tierra, por otra parte, es 11 veces más pequeña que Júpiter,
y la señal es apenas visible en los datos.
Así que de vuelta a nuestro misterio.
Hace unos años los cazadores de planetas depurando datos en busca de tránsitos,
vieron a una misteriosa señal procedente de la estrella KIC 8462852.
Las observaciones en mayo de 2009 fueron las primeras,
y empezaron a hablar de esto en los foros de discusión.
Decían que un objeto igual que Júpiter
haría una caída como esta a la luz de la estrella,
pero también se decía que era gigante.
Los tránsitos normalmente solo duran unas pocas horas,
y este se prolongó durante casi una semana.
También decían que se ve asimétrica,
que significa que en vez de limpieza por inmersión en forma de U como en Júpiter,
tenía esta extraña pendiente que se puede ver en el lado izquierdo.
Esto parecía indicar
que todo lo que estaba en el camino y que bloqueaba la luz de las estrellas
no era circular como un planeta.
Surgieron unas cuantas lagunas,
pero hace un par de años, todo estaba bastante tranquilo.
Y luego, en marzo del 2011, vemos esto:
gotas de luz de la estrella caen en un 15 %,
y esto es enorme en comparación con un planeta,
que solo haría un descenso del 1 %.
Hemos descrito esta característica como algo suave y limpio.
También es asimétrica,
con una atenuación gradual que dura casi una semana,
y que luego vuelve a encajarse con normalidad en solo cuestión de días.
Y de nuevo, después de esto, no sucede gran cosa
hasta febrero de 2013.
Las cosas empiezan a ser realmente de locos.
Hay un enorme complejo de caídas en la curva de luz en la que aparecen,
y duran unos 100 días,
todo el tiempo hasta el final de la misión Kepler.
Estas caídas tienen formas diversas.
Algunas son muy afiladas, y otras son anchas,
y también tienen duraciones variables.
Algunas duran solo un día o dos, otras más de una semana.
Y también hay tendencias hacia arriba y abajo en algunas de estas caídas,
como si superpusieran varios eventos independientes.
Y en este momento, esta estrella cae en su brillo más del 20 %.
Esto significa que todo lo que bloquea su luz
tiene una superficie de más de 1000 veces la superficie de nuestro planeta Tierra.
Esto es verdaderamente notable.
Y por lo que los científicos voluntarios, al ver esto,
notificaron al equipo científico que encontraron algo bastante raro
que podría valer la pena hacer un seguimiento.
Y así, cuando el equipo científico lo observó,
pensamos: "Sí, es probable que haya algo malo con los datos".
Pero nos parecía muy, muy, muy difícil,
y los datos eran buenos.
Y así lo que estaba pasando tenía que ser astrofísico,
lo que significa que algo en el espacio estaba en el camino
bloqueando la luz estelar.
Y así, en este punto,
empezamos a aprender todo lo posible sobre la estrella
para poder encontrar pistas sobre lo que estaba ocurriendo.
Y los científicos ciudadanos que nos han ayudado en este descubrimiento,
se unieron a lo largo del paseo
viendo la ciencia en acción en primera persona.
En primer lugar, alguien dijo: ¿y si esta estrella era muy joven
y todavía tenía alrededor la nube de material de la que nace?
Y entonces otro dijo:
¿qué pasaría si la estrella tuviera planetas ya formados,
y dos de estos planetas hubieran colisionado,
similar a la formación de la Tierra-Luna.
Pues bien, estas dos teorías podrían explicar parte de los datos,
pero las dificultades eran que la estrella no parecía ser joven,
y no había resplandor de cualquiera de los materiales
que se calentaban por la luz de la estrella,
y que se puede esperar, si la estrella era joven
o si hubo una colisión y se produjo una gran cantidad de polvo.
Y así que alguien más ha dicho,
¿Y si hay un enorme enjambre de cometas
pasando por esta estrella en una órbita muy elíptica?
Esto realmente es consistente con nuestras observaciones.
Pero estoy de acuerdo, parece algo artificial.
Se necesitarían cientos de cometas
para reproducir lo que observamos.
Y estos son solo los cometas
que pasan entre nosotros y la estrella.
Y así, en realidad, estamos hablando de miles a decenas de miles de cometas.
Pero de todas las malas ideas que teníamos,
esta fue la mejor.
Y así seguimos adelante y publicamos nuestros hallazgos.
Este fue uno de los artículos más difíciles que he escrito.
Se supone que los científicos deben publicar resultados,
y esta situación estaba lejos de eso.
Por eso decidimos darle un título atractivo,
y lo llamamos: "¿Dónde está el flujo?"
Voy a dejar que Uds. resuelvan el acrónimo.
(Risas)
Pero esto no es el final de la historia.
Casi al mismo tiempo que yo escribía este artículo,
me encontré con un colega mío, Jason Wright,
que también estaba escribiendo un artículo sobre datos de Kepler.
Y decía que con la extrema precisión de Kepler,
podría detectar megaestructuras alienígenas alrededor de las estrellas,
pero no fue así.
Le mostré los datos que los voluntarios científicos habían encontrado,
y me dijo:
"Tonterías, Tabby.
Ahora tengo que reescribir mi artículo".
Así que sí, las explicaciones naturales eran débiles,
y ahora teníamos curiosidad.
Así que tuvimos que encontrar una manera de descartar alienígenas.
Así que juntos, convencimos a un colega nuestro
que trabaja en SETI, la búsqueda de inteligencia extraterrestre,
que este sería un objetivo extraordinario para perseguir.
Escribimos una propuesta para observar la estrella
con el mayor radiotelescopio del mundo en el Observatorio de Green Bank.
Un par de meses más tarde,
la noticia de esta propuesta se filtró a la prensa
y ahora hay miles de artículos,
más de 10 000 artículos sobre esta estrella sola.
Y si se busca Google,
se encontrará esto.
Ahora, podrían preguntar: "Bien, Tabby, así
¿cómo se explican los alienígenas esta curva la luz?"
Bueno, imaginen una civilización mucho más avanzada que la nuestra.
En este caso hipotético,
esa civilización habría agotado la energía de su planeta de origen,
Entonces, ¿dónde podrían obtener más energía?
Ellos tienen una estrella madre al igual que nosotros tenemos el sol,
y si fuesen capaces de capturar más energía de esta estrella,
entonces eso resolvería sus necesidades energéticas.
Así que irían y construirían estructuras enormes.
Estos gigantes, megaestructuras
como los paneles solares descomunales, se denominan esferas de Dyson.
Esta imagen de arriba contiene
un montón de impresiones artísticas de las esferas de Dyson.
Es muy difícil ofrecer una perspectiva sobre la inmensidad de estas cosas,
pero se puede pensar de esta manera.
La distancia Tierra-Luna es de unos 400 000 km.
El elemento más simple en una de estas estructuras
es 100 veces ese tamaño.
Son enormes.
Ahora imaginen una de estas estructuras en movimiento alrededor de una estrella.
Se puede ver cómo se produciría anomalías en los datos
como, por ejemplo, caídas poco naturales irregulares.
Pero lo cierto es que incluso las megaestructuras exóticas
no pueden desafiar las leyes de la física.
Cualquier cosa que usa gran cantidad de energía
produce calor,
pero eso no observamos.
Pero podría ser algo tan simple
como que están irradiando en otra dirección,
no hacia la Tierra.
Otra idea que es una de mis favoritas
es que hemos sido testigos de una batalla en el espacio interplanetario
y de la destrucción catastrófica de un planeta.
Ahora, admito que esto produciría una gran cantidad de polvo
que no se observa.
Pero si invocamos a alienígenas en esta explicación,
entonces ¿quién puede decir que no limpiaron eficientemente todo
para reciclar?
(Risas)
Se puede ver cómo esto rápidamente capta su imaginación.
Bueno, ahí lo tienen.
Estamos en una situación que podría revelarse
como un fenómeno natural que no entendemos
o una tecnología alienígena que no entendemos.
En lo personal, como científica, voy por la explicación natural.
Pero no me malinterpreten, creo que sería increíble encontrar extraterrestres.
De cualquier manera, siempre hay algo nuevo e interesante para descubrir.
Entonces, ¿qué pasa después?
Tenemos que seguir observando esta estrella
para aprender más sobre lo que pasa.
Pero los astrónomos profesionales como yo,
tenemos recursos limitados para este tipo de cosas,
y Kepler está en una misión diferente.
Y estoy feliz de decir que, una vez más,
los ciudadanos científicos han entrado y salvado el día.
En esta ocasión,
astrónomos aficionados con sus telescopios caseros
intensificaron y comenzaron a observar esta estrella nocturna
en sus propias instalaciones,
y estoy muy emocionada de ver lo que encuentran.
Me sorprende que esta estrella nunca fue detectada por las computadoras
porque simplemente no buscábamos algo así.
Y lo que es más emocionante
es que hay más datos en el futuro.
Hay nuevas misiones que están surgiendo
que están observando a millones de estrellas
por todo el cielo.
Y piensen: ¿Qué significará cuando nos topemos con otra estrella de esta manera?
Y ¿qué significa si no encontramos otra estrella de esta manera?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)